votaram todos estou aqui meu nome é hips
próprios falar como foi anunciado sobre
o conhecimento uma aventura da
consciência e conhecimento é um sucesso
tremendo surpreender leva algumas
pessoas a enfrentar as portas ao varzim
leva outros a descobrir e conquistar a
lua e em qualquer desses extremos
nós encontramos sempre triste comum que
procurar de eureka descobrir qualquer
coisa
todos conhecem a história saiu do banho
a correr talvez até do o tal era a
paixão do conhecimento e da descoberta
depois de ter verificado com nós todos
aprendemos qualquer corpo embrulhado num
fui que sofre uma impulsão vertical de
baixo para cima igual ao peso do
guidismo carro
só que esta visão e esta descoberta
científica todos nós estamos habituados
não é o uso mais correto do conhecimento
no dia a dia nós temos um conhecimento
para servir os nossos interesses mais
imediatos é o senso comum que nos guia
para procurar alimentos para saber
quando acordamos onde está o despertador
o hotel é nova ou para ir nos conduzir o
carro enfim para as mil e uma atividades
cotidianas são guiadas também
publicidade uma descoberta perceber que
cremos o reclamos mexendo guiados por
nós 131 conhecimento que nós quisermos
ser objeto
o show humanidade tivesse ficado apenas
por aqui não trigo longe
como alguém disse e da água pedras não
acabou por falta de pedra a cabo por que
alguém se lembrou do ir mais longe
descobrir mais qualquer coisa mudar as
tecnologias e essa aventura maravilhosa
que nos trouxe até ao século 21 os
progressos no conhecimento mas também
com os riscos que comporta se pensarmos
um pouco nessas duas atitudes e tal
atitude que diz conhecer e como
respeitar
g1 o que está ali agora lá fora essa
primeira atitude em que o conhecimento é
pouco mais que uma curiosidade que
procura satisfazer tem como ser outro
pólo a outro aqui tudo que é bom mas nós
damos atenção ao que sucedem quando
estamos a conhecer depois talvez sejamos
capaz de vencer
com isso sem dar atenção ao que sucede
quando estamos acontecer significa que
ganhámos consciência de um método de
etapas de fácil através das quais nós
podemos ser precisamente porque eles
tornando subtópicos podemos repetir
é essa nossa é essas etapas que nos
levaram a fazer descobertas reais e
aperfeiçoando a chegar
então aquilo que se chama o conhecimento
científico
o cientista é alguém tem que ser
maravilhosa - 39 a sua caricatura do
cientista esta vez do o famoso choro
girassol quem tem fim
nenhum os outros igual pra todo mundo
anda linha pró acompanhar para o tamanho
não está imerso nas suas descobertas
científicas
o dizem até que nos primeiros cientistas
como fomos grego e tals
descoberto ciclo da água e tracker ambos
pode ser uma lenda mas é uma lenda que
também identifica essa maravilhosa
distração do cientista para quem atua
qualquer sujeito e provo possui intenso
mesmo porque nos concentramos objetos
concentrados em tentar ser objetivo liga
só viagem que o tal sua história não
acaba aqui como quase sempre as
histórias foram contadas porque o mar
estava vidro contas a sua capacidade
para visão teológica ou ou todos os
lugares mas aí pro antes vindo a
analisar região da grande graça não
devia ter feito uma fortuna haynes
ganhantes filha dela é um pouco como um
de algumas pessoas
no final do século 20 entre o criador
dos grandes instrumentos que permitem
utilizar os instrumentos enfim de
software e bill gates que foi ter com
elas levem disso eu já sou engenheiro
rogério criou uma coisa maravilhosa eu
também não sou tudo isso bill gates não
quer associar a mim para lançar uma
grande empresa mas pensava em continuar
a dirigir o centro da remoção do é um
bosta de israel sou mais eu sou mais o
eu sou mais chance
o bill gates fez a fantástica carreira e
e prova entre empresário e filantropo
que o caracteriza e significa que a
ciência o conhecimento científico para
ser mais exato
tem sempre como seu horizonte a
possibilidade tecnológica e nós vivemos
numa sociedade em que vivemos é que me
numa sociedade que ainda não encontrou o
seu nome estamos à procura do nome da
cidade para onde vamos
chamou a sociedade da informação sim não
falta
o chamado a sociedade do conhecimento
também é pretendido subiu o seu peso se
lá do risco se lavar as redes
o certo é que é transformação tão grande
certamente como aquela que nos tirou da
revolução agrícola e da revolução
industrial esta revolução da informação
o vovô alguém a dizer que o conhecimento
em particular no século 20
deixou de ser apenas a preocupação dos
sábios os que sabem alguns conhecem o
crescimento ganhou importância com a
questão social porque as grandes
escolhas das nossas sociedades
dependendo das escolhas que nós fizermos
quanto à gestão do conhecimento e
contato e tudo ea consciência com que
nós o procuramos e com que os seus
conhecimento científico é talvez o
melhor que nós temos
do ponto de vista desta aventura desta
capacidade eléctrica não tem limitações
como também procurou a dizer a origem
dos planetas
os batimentos do coração
a nossa respiração tem o que se pode
chamar processo sistemático que o
concelho com alguma
foi assim a primeira cientista tem à sua
frente um conjunto de processos
a chuva ou o olhar pela janela
no carro os pneus de chuva aqueles no
pára brisas ou os toques de um
computador gaga quando se aproxima de um
remate zazo o o o ranking desse wx da
região são sérgio antônio não tem
assistido a atividade organizada que os
que víamos antes para os cientistas
fizeram em particular o enorme salto
caxias e contemporânea conseguiu dar
ciência contemporânea certamente desde
time já começa a falar do seu princípio
mais consigo da seleção começa a falar
do momento da crise
levado à evolução pois certamente nos
modelos da microfísica do max plano e
depois na teoria da relatividade
rousseff pt
vindo da biologia da física passando
pela aqmi que todas as ciências naturais
o a ciência contemporânea foi capaz de
criar o que talvez possamos chamado que
mais freqüência é combinar o sistemático
e metódico e permite combinar porque em
vez de recorrer às funções do nilton
recorrem ao nome do jogo e capacidade de
transporte é uma frase outro físico
enquanto lutava há uma frase muito sobre
isso já é muito difícil
do futuro e acho que a capacidade do
previsão desta capacidade de indicar e
criar modelos deverá reunir alcançou um
esquema de referência os que mais
freqüência
qualquer criança identifica do ciclo do
carbono oxigênio e inclusão imagem das
plantas ao do ciclo da água doce
concretos nas células que regenera um
sonho dos ciclos de fusão do hidrogênio
é óbvio que nos dá tranquilidade e
gangues das estrelas ciências da
natureza identificar em esquemas de
ocorrência útil
o surdo extraordinário do conhecimento
contemporâneo mas ao mesmo tempo eu há
conhecimento contemporâneo uma
testemunha especial quase nós poderíamos
comprar assim uma peça de roupa se pensa
na copa
isto eu tinha fita sabem que tá ali a pf
portal do conhecimento
mas fiquei muito vento o cachoeira roupa
num certo
os nossos museus da realidade são
absolutamente demonstrado mas são
absolutamente precário emergem de um
caos alguma ordem
nós não sabemos mas com a qual podemos
caminhar
o mais interessante é que esta noção de
uma realidade que é construída mas que
está suspensa de novos dados novas
infecções novas hipóteses
este modelo explicativo da rede assuntos
que melhor conhece a pessoa pra ciências
humanas o paciente se acha uma grande
diferença é que sendo a probabilidade
naturais liberdade
humanos porque o objeto estuda um objeto
qualquer é o sujeito humano que tem
decisões
também acho que mais influenciou a
ciclos econômicos ou a ciclos 1
sociológicos ou a ciclos na evolução
psicológica brasil da história discutir
o certo é que também os acontecimentos
humanos
o bessa ea uma capacidade de produzir
cuidados com 17 museus mas não são
apenas intangíveis são também muito
gente quem atua e não é um processo
apenas inclusive qual é um processo
inteligente que o próprio ser humano
ia ser uma crise pode ir lá e essa
triste específica das ciências humanas
são ciências da ação humana envolvida em
grande condicionante em grandes o com o
condicionante de tão fortes que às vezes
nos parece ser determinante da exige ao
cientista ao cientista social exige
também uma fortíssima um forte grau de
consciência
eu tal como o cientista natural sabe que
o conhecimento é poder é uma velha frase
de francis bacon conhecimento é poder de
transformação nas numa outra frase que
também vai investir grandes criadouros
do maniqueísmo renascentista
não pode haver ciência sem consciência
precisamente face ao poder a ciência eo
conhecimento científico está sujeito a
às tentações do poder que não conhece o
que não sabe que não tem consciência que
instrumentaliza a ciência que o juíza os
conhecimentos de física atômica para ou
física nuclear para fazer excluir o
universo nunca o mel do fogo ao culto
isa os conhecimentos de química biologia
para
a modificação transgênica do saurimo - o
que manipulou as formas a lista é longa
e não só a lista é longa
como ela não é fácil existe uma enorme
falta de literacia científica e não sei
lá como prática senão alguém trazia
científica
se as pessoas não estão informadas nos
processos tecnológicos que a ciência tem
à sua disposição têm muita dificuldade
em pronunciar sem energia nuclear
gravava sustentava alimentos
transgênicos questões financeiras que
estão na ordem do dia que se pode fazer
com que os bancários não que eles não
são do que caracterizado pelo
conhecimento
mas enfim os seus moço de recados
financeiros porque eles fizeram com os
algoritmos debate criaram os produtos
todos para trás financeiros que nunca o
mundial finança e que não está a ser
visto com a mesma tudo isso é toda esta
sociedade com que opera sobre o muito
conhecimento e muita informação e que se
torna um risco se nós não formos capazes
de gerir com consciência e que nós temos
que voltar àquela inicial de fato
conhecer não é para a espera estar à
espreita que as coisas apareçam
vencer é formar a consciência para
construirmos a própria realidade de
fazer com que as coisas aconteçam e por
seu conhecimento é uma aventura da
consciência e por isso é crítica de vez
mais em vez de nos lamentarmos uma
famosa música que deu a volta ao país há
dois anos atrás fica dura que eu sou
todos lembram da famosa canção dos
deolinda que faz todo o sentido o uso de
olinda faz todo o sentido para chamar a
atenção
criamos um sistema educativo com alguma
vez
informamos que continuamos a formar uma
geração
razoáveis forte e pois convém autoridade
social
a canção chama a atenção para esta
questão decisiva que é o conhecimento
não é apenas a preocupação de reduzir os
sábios do consumidor sentem menos sódio
universitários
o rendimento é uma questão social e
pensa que a obrigação que nós é aquilo
que eu procuro fazer várias formas de
queda
umas mais ameaçadoras acadêmicas e
outras pra mim por meio de imagens
antigas de cidadania
o que eu procuro fazer é trazer para a
praça pública essa urgência social do
conhecimento
essa urgência de que conhecer não é
saber coisas não estará à espreita não é
enfim conhecer é desenvolver a nossa
consciência no sentido ético
tenho certeza que cada um faz talvez o
que eu peço a cada um faça e quando vai
para o fim do dia para o outro lado a
consciência para quando as luzes se
apagam estela nova se desligam e nós já
conseguimos nos lençóis pensa o que
posso fazer no seu posto de trabalho na
sua vida nos seus contatos para que esta
aventura da consciência não termine e
que se tornam social nem tudo está bem